hello everyone and welcome to another
facebook live interview from the
european parliament here in brussels we
are also live on youtube this time last
week parliament gave its final green
light to the digital markets act and to
the digital services act which are said
to be
game changers of the digital environment
in europe i'm maria of the from the web
communication team of the parliament and
i am joined today by
miss christel chaldemos member of the
parliament leading with one of these two
pieces of legislation at the parliament
the one on content moderation rules
known also as the digital services act
so welcome thanks a lot for being here
today thank you so much for having me
here yeah so before we get underway with
the interview i'd like our audience to
send us your questions and comments and
i'll try to put as many as possible to
my guests in the next half an hour or so
so well let's start
why does the european union need an
update of of the rules for the digital
world
well more or less because we don't
really have any rules the rules we have
in place
uh before
that that works today is the e-commerce
directive and uh it was adopted back in
year 2000 i mean 2000. that's
that is 22 years ago
and that was before
amazon was a good company
it was before steve jobs had thought
about the iphone and it was before
facebook was started so of course the
rules are not really taking into account
the new types of digital services so we
need an update but we also need to make
sure that we can regulate and take back
control because today the big tech
giants are deciding the rules for the
online world
and i want it to be a democratic decided
rulebook we have and that's what we did
with the dsa
so our audience can be confused about
the difference between the digital
services act and the digital markets act
in very simple terms would you explain
what but i think you said it in fact in
a good manner the dsa is about the
content of the platforms and making sure
the rules are clear on that and the dma
the digital market act is about
competition rules so that we can make
sure that we have more platforms so they
can compete better for the benefit of
the users so the dsa is is really where
we're trying to establish the rules for
for the content of the platforms
and do you think that the rest of the
world will follow suit after these
laws were approved
well i don't believe that the rest of
the world will copy-paste the dsa
one-to-one but i think that they will be
inspired so we we have what we call the
brussels effect very often we did it
also with the ddpr we saw that we made
rules uh new rules land marking rules
and then after a certain time other
countries or regions
kind of were inspired and and maybe did
not come
get exactly the same but they were
starting to focus on privacy for
instance on the ddpr and i'm sure that
on the dma
and the dsa they will do
the same at least for the dsa's part
that will probably create uh you know
the standards the golden standards for
the rest of the world i expect that also
on the basis of discussions i've had
with
politicians from other parts of the
world the digital services act aims to
to protect users from my legal content
online on this there are some comments
on facebook for example sky smyths ask
who defines what is and what is not
illegal well that's a very good question
honestly
we are not defining with the dsa what is
legal and what is not legal it's still
up to the member states or to specific
sector-specific legislation we're making
in eu the dsa and it might sound a
little bit technical but it's a
horizontal piece of legislation what
we're saying is that if something is
illegal
then we have rules in place on what how
to tackle that to take it down and and
things like that so and we we harmonized
the rules uh on what to do if you have a
legal content we're also saying who can
identify illegal content but let me give
you an example
we are not harmonizing because in in eu
we still have different ways of looking
at things in germany for instance it is
illegal to
deny that holocaust took place
uh
and that's for good reasons in germany
but in my country denmark it is legal to
deny
we have another history so we are saying
well let's get it out in the open then
we can discuss so the platforms they
have to live with the different
illegal legal rules but for german users
of the platforms
they will see that that for instance
facebook have to take down
has to take down content where people
are denying a holocaust
but for danish users they don't have to
okay yeah it's a bit tricky though
because it depends i mean people
see the content online so they don't
know from which country
it comes from it it's true it's true
to a certain extent but still we we know
very often if you use language
which uh citizens in the european union
it is targeted at so i think it will
work uh
so
so the platforms they have to
realize that if they want to do do
business in europe and for european
users then they have to live with the
fact that we can have different laws on
what is illegal and what is not legal we
we are not harmonizing that but we're
saying if it is legal it needs to be
taken down expeditiously
and how will this be achieved so who
will have the right to tell platforms to
take down illegal content well
it will be many types we have what we
call trusted flaggers
that are certain organization
authorities and things like that that
can flag towards the platform but you
could also as a use of flag
if you see something you believe might
be
illegal and then they have to look at it
and react on it if it is legal but very
often it will probably be still you know
the police in the member states if
somebody has shared a photo that they
did not have contact consent to then and
you can then you can go to the
authorities the police for instance and
then they can contact for instance
facebook or youtube and then they will
have to take it down but it could also
be
ngos it could be consumer organizations
or privacy organizations or or whatever
it could even be companies that could be
a trusted flagger so we're not saying
that the platform should control or
monitor
but if they are getting knowledge about
illegal content then they need to act
it's clear
so according to the rules
harmful content should not be treated
the same way as illegal what's the
difference and how can harmful content
have been be effectively addressed
well
it is in fact difficult
so
we said
crystal clear illegal content needs to
be taken down but you could still have
legal but harmful content so if you have
you know
too much disinformation that could be
harmful but it can still be legal so how
to tackle that we said that we still
want the platforms to take
responsibility for this and that's where
we kind of open up the black box
of algorithms because we're saying to
the platforms well once a year at least
you have to make an impact assessment on
how your algorithm works and when you
look at it you need to see if there are
some system systemic problems so if you
can see that your algorithms works in a
way that
amplifies disinformation or hate speech
or cyber violence or what it could be
and that has a negative impact on users
it could be
harming democracy or harming the health
of young ladies or whatever then they
have to risk mitigate but we're not
telling them how to do it but we say you
need to take responsibility for
responsibility for them systemic risks
your the content on your platforms uh
perform with so i think that we're
league illegal needs to take down be
taken down expeditiously here and now
but for the rest they need to look into
how does that work so if you have for
instance a lot of this information you
can as a platform decide to take it down
but we're not saying that you have to
take it down but you can downgrade it
today
the platforms let me give you an example
on on facebook facebook is
they want to
they are harvesting our data
they want us to stay on the platform so
they can know as much as possible so
they can sell ads targeted at us and in
order to keep us stay on the platform
they want to have us engaged involved
and how to involve us well that is by
making sure that
that we see a lot of maybe negative
content or content that polarized people
because we know that that that type of
content is
creating uh interaction you share you
dislike you comment uh and you maybe
even send out other things to go up
against it so you are active so negative
in
content has
built in it that you you get the users
to be more active rather than positive
you know you can share a cat video i
love that myself looking at it but
you're not getting angry in fact you're
getting calm and you like it but you
don't necessarily stay or you don't
necessarily share but that that will you
do if it's very uh negative
so here we're saying
this is not necessarily illegal but it
can still be harmful to democracy
and therefore they have to risk mitigate
as we call it so they have to do
something look into their algorithms
and often i would
probably guess that the platforms would
instead of taking it down
i mean if it violates the terms and
conditions they can take it out
but uh but if it doesn't they could
downgrade it instead of amplifying it so
that's what i hope they will do and that
that is what i expect they will do so
that we can make sure that
the
the democracy can work better i mean
it's very important that people still
have their
right to speak freely and therefore also
share a lot of content
but the platforms uh
i mean we know for instance from my
country denmark we know that many women
they don't like to take part in the
political debates online because the
tone is very harsh very tough not very
nice so they kind of tend to
withdraw from the debate online and
since facebook and other other of these
platforms has become public spaces
for democrat democratic dialogues then
it's a problem and that's why i think
that it can harm democracy if we don't
ask platforms to do something and now
they have to do something we're not
saying what to do but we say you have to
do it if it has a negative impact
you have just mentioned a freedom of
speech of
the users and actually this is something
which concerns
our our users on facebook especially
many of them they are afraid that these
rules will mean censorship i would like
to i would like to read a comment from
thomex korika who is afraid that eu
leaders intentions are bad and avoiding
hate speech speech
would result in avoiding freedom of
speech so how can well i i understand
his fear
but i don't think that he is writing
having that fear because we are not
asking the platforms to take down hate
speech but today
they amplify
they make sure that more and more people
see it
because that gives interaction and then
they can harvest our data
we are saying that if we have too much
hp we don't have a real freedom of
speech for everyone so we suggest that
if it has a negative impact if it's a
systemic failure from the platforms then
they have to do something they could for
instance downgrade so that it is not
shown as often but if you search on it
you will still find it but it it's not
they don't in their recommendation
uh amplifies it so so i think that he
shouldn't be afraid i think that there
is a misunderstanding we are not asking
the platforms to make filters we are not
asking the platforms to make a general
monitoring of us we are only saying that
if users flagger trusted [ __ ] are are
flagging something then the platforms
need to look into it and they have to
look into it also on their algorithms
once a year and then adapt so i think
that we have what we could call an arm
length principle in place we ask the
platforms to act
we're not saying how to act we're saying
if there is a systemic risk they have to
change the algorithms and risk mitigate
will there be penalties penalties if
they don't
yes
ultimately if a platform doesn't comply
with the dsa rule they will
have to risk a fine
on up to six percent
of the global turnover which is rather
much but then of course
it's because then they have seriously
breached the terms
sorry the the the legislation
but i think that and i hope that
the high level of fines can
somehow prevent the platforms from
from doing something legal so i hope and
i guess that they will try to do what
they can to comply but i don't think
that people should be afraid it's not
the law
that is a problem with the dsa we are
not saying that they should take down or
restrict the freedom of speech but we
say that if there is a systemic risk and
there is a risk of of harming people's
fundamental rights or harming public
health or harming democracy then i have
to look into it and see how it can work
good so i think it was a very good
answer and i hope that our audience is
more aware
of this right now and on this there is a
nice comment of nils who is saying
excellent job crystal carrion thank you
so much
what if user's content is removed but
it's not illegal can they
contest their decisions somehow yeah
this is some of the things that i'm
really really i'm happy about much of
the things we're doing but
we are really trying to give users of
the platforms more rights
so if
if an account is closed down they need
to notify the user
if some content is taken down the user
will be notified with a reason and you
have to write a complaint first
internally at the platform and if you're
not satisfied with the ruling then you
can go to an out of court
settlement
and
dispute settlement it's called
and their ask also to have them to look
at it and and if you're still not
satisfied then of course you can go to
the courts but i think that that this
give users more rights we're also saying
to the platforms that they need to be
very clear in the way they're
giving people
knowledge about for instance terms and
condition
it needs to be
if you're a spanish you need to have it
in spanish
maybe you already have that today
because spanish is a big language but
for instance you don't know for sure
that it always is in danish and we want
the platforms to write their terms and
conditions in an understandable way but
also in the european languages
that are are used in
the users so in many ways i think that
we're giving
users more rights
and that is very important and that's no
matter whether your many businesses are
using the platforms to reach customers
or you're a consumer buying goods or
services or you are a citizen who wants
to express your points of views or your
uh your views on things and no matter
what kind you should have some rights uh
and that's what we're trying to to give
people even if you want to get into
contact with the platforms where also
today people can write you know in a box
in a form and send it away and you never
know if it's
there if it's received and you will not
necessarily be given
an answer by email or something like
that we are giving the users the right
also to decide what in what way you want
to get into contact with the platforms
so if you want to write an email that
should be your
right as well
so you said that yeah with this
legislation users will have more rights
and
are there other ways where in
which the dsa will improve the public
scrutiny for online platforms
yeah i mean we are
when we talk about uh
enforcement for instance because we have
the rules in place and as always
companies have to follow the rules
but if they don't or just to make sure
that they're doing it we have decided
that the eu commission will be
responsible for the enforcement of the
very large online platforms meaning you
know for instance facebook
google youtube
so we are saying that the eu commission
will have to look into
whether the big platforms are complying
or not but not just the commission
also
researchers will get access to data and
even ndos if they are vetted will have
it right to get access we need more to
help us
monitoring whether the platforms are
doing what they're supposed to do or not
so i think that we are giving
the whole society a chance to you know
follow
and take part of this and i think that
that's needed because the platforms at
least a very large one they're so big
and they decide so much that it's fair
that the society who will be impacted by
the platforms that they also have a
chance to to look at it and give their
point of view on whether they like it or
not
when i was reading about this
legislation i saw that there is a there
are some closest on the protection of
miners as well so in general how will
the digital services act to protect
fundamental rights well in general we
have said for for miners we said two
things we said that the platforms that
are particularly
targeting
miners it could be tick-tock
they have to
make their design
designed in a way that fits miners
you know there are different
ways of doing this but if you're a miner
and you not
necessarily know how to read
terms and conditions and things like
that then you have to design it in
another way than if it's primarily
adults we also say that
we
want them to make sure that it is a safe
online environment for for miners and
finally we're banning that miners can be
targeted with ads
because
we would like you know in order
the platform's
business model is
to harvest our data
in order to sell ads
and these ads the more they know about
us the more they can micro target us
because they know what we are interested
in who we where we who we interact with
what kind of
interests we have
sounds scary
yes and this is not even that they also
know our sexual orientation they know
our political affiliation they know our
religion they know everything
and even especially for minors i think
this is horrible but they have to
profile the miners so we are saying at
least we ban that you are not allowed to
to to make this micro targeting and
therefore we hope that by that they will
not profile minders for the rest of us
for the adults they can still target us
but they will not be allowed to target
us with ads on the basis of for instance
our our religion
or political affiliation so we have said
that sensitive data will not be allowed
to be used for targeted ads so we're
going into the business model of the
platforms and try to you know protect
users better than today and i think
that's very very important it's not sure
that you will feel the difference but it
will become more safe and you will get
less
personalized ads in the future and
personally i like that
there is another user who likes that as
well so as you said under the new rules
tech companies will also face tighter
restrictions and you see on using
people's data for targeted online ads
and mark margaret cos it's um hopeful
about the new legislation so she says
it's like having a like having hidden
eyes and ears in your house um soaking
you in every word and thought enough is
enough i welcome this action
oh i'm so happy to hear that and i share
her points of views it's it's kind of
scary yeah and i think
we had been a little bit too slow
to interfere in this but now we do it
with the dma and the dsa so we will put
up restrictions and they are not allowed
to do whatever they would like to do we
need to protect people's uh privacy much
more than we have done so far
will the digital services act do
anything about the so-called dark
patterns
yes
we are banning dark patterns and then
sometimes people ask me what is that
pattern but that's that's when the
platforms uses
techniques to manipulate us into making
a decision that we would maybe not have
done many knows there are different
types of dark patterns but one of the
most well known is that if you have have
these choices do you want to give away
your data and then the green button is
the one where you say yes and then the
gray
one or
more faded one is the one where you say
no
and that is in a way they usually
manipulate us to say yes because we tend
to it's easier to see the green through
and it's it's a it's a positive color
kind of so people tend to to push
for that and we will we don't want to
have that we want to have a real
decision made by the users we don't want
to be manipulated so that's why we're
banning dark patterns
we i'm curious myself about
seeing how this will be in the real
world how much they will do because i
guess that the platforms still would
like to
nudge us into doing things but at least
they're not allowed to manipulate us so
we're banning that
and how how will the digital services
act protect people from unsafe or
counterfeit goods
well
one of the things we're trying to do for
goods sold online is that we are saying
that the platforms need to take
responsibility to know who the seller is
so they need to have real knowledge
about who the seller is and they also
need to make sample tests of the
products
and then we have the trusted flaggers it
could be companies
you know
companies that are selling the real
product the not non-quantified
counterfeited product they can also help
platforms to find the counterfeited
products products so i think that we're
doing more
i will not guarantee people that they
will
be free of counterfeited products but i
hope that with the rules it will be a
little bit more difficult for for those
who wants to cheat
let's hope so
but but
honestly on this we don't we are not
really finished okay i think that we
need to work more
we have more to do when it comes to
online marketplaces so we still have to
find our ways and and hopefully
we will be able to
have a stronger regulation sooner on on
this because we're not really finalized
but we took some steps in the right
direction and hopefully we can we can do
more i guess at a certain time when it
becomes
more normal
to buy to shop online
many does it today especially young
people but we can see on the on the
figures that there are still many people
using the offline shops
but since more and more people will show
up online we will see more and more
problems so i guess that we have to do
more and and i myself will push more for
it but we're taking small but important
steps in the right direction
and when will this legislation come into
force the digital services yeah but
that's one of the good things because
normally it takes ages
for eu legislation to be applicable for
the companies
but we just adopted the final
piece of legislation now and already
next year in springtime 23
we will the the rules for the online for
the very large online platforms will be
applicable
so uh if we were sitting here next time
next year at the same time we would
already be able to see the differences
for the very large online platforms and
for the rest it's the 1st of january
2024 but already spring 23 the new rules
will be applicable for the very large
online platforms
so on a more personal level i would like
to ask you how was this experience of
negotiating such an important file in
record time as well
well
i didn't do much besides working on the
dsa during this process we it was very
very
uh time-consuming but so interesting and
so important so you know that's the most
important and most satisfying thing i've
done politically was to work with the
dsa it will have a huge impact on
citizens not just in europe but also
outside europe
and what we did here is in fact
something that will
benefiting democracy benefiting the
level playing field for companies and
also benefiting uh
the consumer protection and so in
general the democracy the society will
will have it better will will be better
once this is applicable and who doesn't
want to be able to say that i made a
difference and i feel that i did that on
this so it has been
very very interesting very very
tough but i'm so proud of the result and
here at the parliament we really did a
good job and and we had a strong uh
negotiating team who really together
wanted to to make a difference and we
ended up doing that
so miss salimos thanks a lot for your
time i wish you very well deserved
holidays after all these negotiations
and yeah thanks a lot for being here and
thank you to our followers for tuning in
once again have a good afternoon
everyone good afternoon as well
you